thank you so much for the nice
introduction and thank you all for
coming i'm really excited to be here i'm
hoping to keep this pretty informal so
if you have questions definitely feel
free to interrupt me raise your hand and
we'll just take it as we go so as
Michael said I was a graduate student at
the University of Washington before i
joined adobe and there I was actually
started out as a computer graphics
researcher and I did work in animation
and image compositing and then I came
over to the to the good side and started
doing HCI and and finished my thesis in
in HD eyes as Michael just described and
when it was time to graduate I was
really excited to look at Adobe and to
go to Adobe and this because they make
software that's really near and dear to
my heart how many we have have heard of
a Photoshop almost all of you now how
many of you have used Photoshop okay
good now how many of you are using it 15
years ago wow I might be the only one in
this room it's never happened to me that
that I'm the only one but but trust me i
was using it 15 years ago and here um
here's my classroom i was i was in high
school at the time and I was really
really into photography and when I
discovered photoshop i was in heaven all
of a sudden I could make art I could
take the analog pictures that I was
producing and combine them in all cool
and different ways and this is remember
before the age of the digital camera but
let's fast forward 15 years so what
happens today well I still take lots and
lots of pictures but I'm not an artist
um that's what I was aspiring to be back
then what i do now in Photoshop is very
different I tend to go in and I only
have a few minutes not hours and I just
want to make my pictures look good I
don't want to make artistic compositions
and in fact when we look at our user
base or a look at photo shops user base
the majority of people who use the
software are like me and this despite
the fact that the software was designed
for professionals for artists and for
photographers
many of them struggle with the software
the same way I do and the the the the
software is incredibly incredibly rich
there's many many options but it can be
very difficult to walk up to it and just
get going and today I'm going to spend a
lot of time talking about Photoshop
mainly because that's where we've been
doing our experiments but what I'm going
to tell you about is not unique to
photoshop adobe makes a number of other
software that has the same problems and
i would argue in fact many of our
desktop softwares have this challenge if
you've ever tried to write a paper in
word or do your taxes in Excel you've
probably struggled just the same way
that um you would have struggled with
with Photoshop um so here is a sense for
what the talk will look like today first
we'll look at what actually happens when
people try to use visual design software
like Photoshop where do they go when
they struggle and then we'll look at
some of the research projects that we've
been building to try and make this
easier so um along with my colleagues at
Adobe we looked at what happens what do
people do when they encounter a task
they don't know how to do in a software
like Photoshop and in particular we had
three research questions first how do
people approach looking for help where
do they go do they ask a friend do they
open the browser did they go to a search
engine or do they come to Adobe's
website trying to find the right answer
second what types of content are most
useful and this this question is because
we've looked at video and text and try
to understand what's useful about these
different kinds of formats and we found
that you know video there's tons of
video out there it's easy to produce but
it can be hard to figure out whether
this is a good video in contrast text is
easy to scan but maybe it doesn't
include all the details and so we were
really curious to see which form which
instructional content format is
preferred and then finally there are
lots and lots of examples out there of
how to do things in software like
Photoshop but are people able to take
these examples and translate them to
their own task
invariably the examples out there are
not exactly the same as what the user is
trying to accomplish how easy is it for
them to generalize those examples and
follow on with them in their own context
so to answer these questions we brought
some people into the lab we asked them
to do some tasks and we watched them and
we asked them questions and they did one
task that they knew how to do and then
one or two more that they were
unfamiliar with and here we use the
Photoshop 3d tools you may not know this
but Photoshop has 3d tools at inside of
it and so you can manipulate 3d objects
so what happened well what we found is
that when we ask people where they go to
help for help they invariably tell us
that they go to the web for help and
this I mean this is in this day and age
really not that surprising but really
what we're finding is that people are
learning opportunistically they're
opening pieces of software and assuming
that they will figure out how to use
them and when they can't figure out how
to use them they go to the web for help
so what happened in our actual study
well when given the task in this case
take this can and put it on that table
what people did is they started
tinkering they would try to touch
different menus and try to find the
right tools and tinker their way to the
solution some people were successful but
most were not and so when they when they
had a hard time they would go to their
favorite search engine they would query
look at various options go back refine
their query keep looking when they found
a document that seemed appropriate they
would keep it up open side by side and I
would bounce back and forth between the
application and that I'm document trying
to follow the instructions if they were
successful they declared success and if
not they would go back to tinkering and
hoping that now that they've read a
little bit maybe they could tinker in a
more effective way so um um search was
was so back to our research question how
do people approach looking for help
search was was
by far the the thing that everyone did
they search different places so not
everybody went to a Google or Bing they
would go to youtube or they'd go to
adobe's website and but invariably
everybody would search and they would
issue and refine their queries if we
look at the kinds of queries people made
and you'll find a few interesting things
first off the queries tend to be on the
longer side but that's probably because
they include the software and version
number in their queries but more
interestingly if we compare the kinds of
queries professionals make to those that
that novices make you'll see a fairly
interesting difference when people try
to take that can and put on that table
they have to resize it they had to make
it smaller a professional knows that to
make that can't smaller involves the
scaling or transformation tool a novice
on the other hand doesn't know that
language so what this novice tried to do
with shrink that can reduce the size of
that can and that's not the language
that Photoshop understands and so when
they went in query Google using these
keywords they had a hard time finding
the right the right documents another
interesting thing came about in our
third task where we asked people to put
text on a 3d object so if you don't know
how to do this you probably go to to a
search engine and type add text to a 3d
object or add type to a 3d object what
you'll discover if you do that is that
the first the top results for that query
show you how to make text look 3d and
why is that well that's just a more
popular query that's just a more popular
task to do in Photoshop not a lot of
people use the 3d tools and so tutorials
that have to do with the 3d tools don't
show up up at the top so what this
really speaks to is that text is not
really a insufficient way to query for
help when you're struggling with a
visual design application which you'd
really like to be able to do is actually
point to things in that app or point to
objects that you're working with what if
i could say i want to make the size of
this
it's smaller or I'd like to you know why
is this menu item disabled what if a
search engine could take it is input not
just text but other kinds of objects yes
that's on the same vocabulary problem
where I would pointed spoons i really
want to shrink this it says does not
know shrink and you still have to figure
out a scale is the worst it wants its
right the dougie preferences results yes
that's about it that's correct and I'll
show you what we're trying to do with it
with a vocabulary problem next but yes
so to address the vocabulary problem we
really need like a natural language
system that takes your vocabulary and
translates it to the vocabulary of the
application for some with interesting is
that for some popular things like
selection Google will already do this
because there are documents out there
that say oh if you want to do selection
and Photoshop here are the ten tools you
might consider but for more obscure
things like the 3d tools you really need
something else to do this mapping
between the users language and the
applications language post on yahoo
answers that says i want to shrink
something and someone says oh you mean
scale and that's enough it's right so
you could mean that for sure using like
a forum or discussion board is one way
to alleviate that although you could
imagine a system that mines that type of
data and tries to make recommendations
so one of our other questions was what
types of content are more useful so here
remember videos are very popular they're
very easy to make but they can be hard
to use for instructional content mostly
because they're never at the same pace
as your as the person who is using the
software and also they're hard to scan
and you know not all videos are are
useful um so what was surprising T to us
was actually that the choice of text and
images / video had nothing to do with
the instructional quality of those
materials it was entirely a personal
preference some people went directly to
YouTube and only looked for videos and
other people avoid
videos like the plague they felt like oh
I don't know about the quality of videos
and oh I'm in a meeting and oh if a
video started playing that would
horribly embarrassing so um this was
rinse you know despite you know from a
researchers perspective we were really
interested in the instructional quality
and how that influenced success rates
but no they they were much more
interested in like the format itself and
then so finally once people find
examples let's assume they can get
through this vocabulary problem and find
relevant examples are they able to use
those examples in there it further to
solve their task and here we found these
two different strategies one is the slow
and steady strategy and one is the fast
and frantic strategy so the slow and
steady user will will take a document or
video and watch it very carefully and be
very slow and methodical and trying to
understand what's happening the fast and
frantic person is just scanning
scrolling and trying to see okay is this
the right thing and where can I find the
right piece of thing to help me solve my
problem and you know neither of these
strategies was actually better than the
other they all had the same kind of
problem which is that if the tutorial
didn't fit the context of the user it
was often hard to translate it and so
what does it mean to not fit the context
well first off it could be that the
objects that you're manipulating are
different enough that you can't actually
just blindly follow what the tutorial is
telling you so here you have an image
being applied to a can that's not the
same thing as putting text on a can so I
you know you would have to make
modifications to this particular example
to make it work so that's one problem
the other problem was that the state of
the application changes as you do the
tutorial and so if your state doesn't
match the state of the tutorial then you
might see different menus and different
things might be enabled and so users
were often very confused when the thing
that that the tutorial would tell them
to do was actually not available to them
in their own applications and so we
really need better ways to be able to
synchronize
what's happening in this tutorial with
what's happening in the context of the
application so at the highest level the
findings from this this some study where
first off there's really a problem
around missing vocabulary and second
users have a hard time generalizing from
example techniques so to try to address
these challenges we've been developing a
number of different projects and the
first one I'll talk about is the natural
language interface which really tries to
get at this vocabulary problem then
we'll look at how we might synchronize
tutorials and applications and then
finally we've been looking at games and
whether we can use games as a mechanism
to help the users overcome an
overwhelming interface so um when we
started looking at editing with natural
language we thought that natural
language would give us two benefits one
of them is through inventing the the pro
application language and the other one
was we felt that you could use a
language to be more efficient so you
could imagine saying something to the
computer that would take multiple steps
so the example I'll show you says
something like make the shadows on the
left slightly brighter so that's one
sentence um you know takes a second for
me to say it and it results in a
multi-step workflow and so we built a
system to explore these ideas and here
we go and here's a video showing that
system this is a collaboration with
folks at the University of Michigan
everyone takes pictures but photo
editing can be hard
you have to learn how to adjust colors
select objects and improve the lighting
we have created a system that lets you
talk to your computer and tell it what
you want to do with your images if you
wanted to improve the sunset you could
say darken the mid-tones at the top so
that the effect is only applied to that
area and tonal range a slider allows you
to adjust the results now the ocean is
too washed out so increase the contrast
at the bottom that's better you can also
use touch gestures to describe where to
edit blur in this direction you can even
use words that aren't specific to photo
editing for example make it heavenly
now let's do some work on this picture
of my friend Sarah and Jon one thing you
can do is teach the system about what's
in the picture this is a shirt and with
face detection it's easy to indicate who
is here this is Sarah
this is John now you can refer to those
things as you make edits for instance
change the color of the shirt now
Sarah's face looks a little too flushed
decrease the saturation on Sarah both of
them look a little dark brighton Sarah
and Jon there we go a few gesture marks
and crop to here to finish you can apply
popular effect filters make it retro
so in that in these examples you notice
that there's both so we explored support
both for novices so make it heavenly or
make it retro as well as for experts we
have better understanding of that
language like annoying things about
contrast or brightness so how does pixel
tone work well at the highest level we
take gesture commands speech commands
and we combine those and turn them into
image editing operations so what does
that mean well we take the speech we
turn it into text we map that text to
image operations and we combine it with
spatial operations that may be coming
either from the gesture input or from
the speech itself so let's take a look
at a specific example just to make this
a little more concrete so here we have
the example make the shadows on the left
side slightly brighter or slightly
bright in this case so we take the
speech and we convert to text to do this
we have a two part system first we have
a recognition module that runs directly
on the device that's tuned with a finite
vocabulary that's specific to the image
editing domain so that's something
that's quite fast and can turn that
speech into text quickly but of course
if the user uses words that aren't in
our vocabulary then we need some way to
turn that into text and so for that we
go to a general-purpose cloud service
that gives us txt enter in return for
the speech after we get the text we
actually have to now figure out how to
map that text to the image operations
and figure out which part of the phrase
has the image operation in which parts
have the parameters so to do that we
first parse the phrase into parts of
speech so in this case make is the verb
expression the now an expression is
shadows on the left side the adjective
is slightly bright and once we have this
parse we compare it to a set of
templates and its really the templates
that tell us where the image operations
are and where the parameters are so here
bright is actually what corresponds to
the image operation and that
it's under the adjective the nouns tell
us where to apply this operation so in
this case the shadows on the left side
and the adverb slightly tells us
parameter value so how much should we
address that brightness um of course we
might see words that we don't know right
our model only understands a certain set
of image operations or at least for the
moment if you say one we don't know then
we have to map it to something we do
understand and we need to do that will
you sit in and matching so in the case
of energetic we try and see do any of
the things we know how to do closely
relate to energetic in this case vibrant
is similar to energetic and so on the
system applies the vibrance filter
really worth that to do this in a
nematic yeah and then finally and we
execute the operation and because we
expect that the user would want to
manipulate that parameters we give the
user a slider to control that brightness
so we don't have to they don't have to
use speech to do that part of the key to
this we believe is to have a multimodal
interface we're using speech and touch
and concert of course the system fails
sometimes and when it can't understand
what you want it actually just gives you
a gallery of options that you can apply
to your image so we showed the system to
a number of users we actually had them
do a comparison of of the app you saw
one with a speech interface and one
without and almost everybody preferred
using speech and um so this is
encouraging and I think one of the
things that we found was it people off
already had biases about speech
interfaces and how poorly or well they
operate so there was already some amount
of hesitancy one user in particular felt
that you know initially I had doubts
about the speech interface because my
experience tells me that speech doesn't
really work in other apps but this one
that worked well I think it's
better than Cirie and you know I think
for this user it really depends on what
they tried to do a Serie and you know
this is very domain-specific and so
perhaps that's why it operates better
user six says it's possible that my
parents and grandparents could use this
we haven't tried it with you know a lot
of different age groups but it's
certainly very very encouraging um so in
the end I think editing with natural
language it is really um has lots of
potential and it really is again about
these two things users can use their own
language and can really avoid having to
learn these very complicated image
editing techniques and tools and for
those advanced users there's really this
opportunity to do this two things more
quickly and we're right now really
excited about this multi multi modal
editing and trying to see how we can
take what we learned on the iPad and
translate it back into the Photoshop
world in the desktop yes sorry Tim I uh
so I'm curious about people who did not
use the species use a different sorry
did they used it because then i'm using
saying google search and then if i'm
speaking to it i speak differently than
compiling to it mmm so sorry i should
have made this more clear so the people
who didn't get the speech in her face
they were not able to query with natural
language at all so they they were just
given a normal photo editing style
interface which has menus and it had a
gallery actually the fallback gallery
that you saw is what they were given so
they could still use the touch gestures
and select but they could not actually
give it a natural language but I agree
with you you know searching with with
keywords is different than talking than
people think it's more natural which is
again a bottom teeth at be asking too
many mattress but in this little
especially if your client earlier at
national language may be taking speaking
struck by Luke Perry when it seems like
a very clever yeah also me I think in
the tablet world it's kind of an awkward
thing to be typing and and using
gestures at the same time I think in a
desktop world where people are not as
open to talking because there may be in
an office environment and I think that
would be a really interesting thing to
try this something that we're we're
looking forward to trying i'm and and
you know i haven't seen anything that
compares spoken queries versus typed
queries if you're familiar with with
work i'd love to see it because you know
i'd be interesting to know if if it's
just a subset and if it's just the
subset then how do you pick out that
subset from the natural language to make
it more more keyword like if you may um
any other questions i'm going to move on
to the next part of the talk okay so um
so in the next part i'll tell you a bit
about how we've been looking at
synchronizing tutorials and applications
and in particular i'll tell you about a
project called tutorial player which is
an app that and several of us in the lab
built and deployed and so I'll play this
video and i'll just talk over it so
tutorial player is an ipad app here on
the right and it's a tutorial
application that any of you could
actually download off the app store
today what's special about it is that it
talks to photoshop over the network so
here you see a screen screen capture of
your desktop that's the ipad and so you
can connect your iPad to photoshop and
what that means is that every step in
this tutorial that you view in this
application is now interactive so every
step in that tutorial has a show me
button and you can press that show me
button and that step is then executed in
your application and the idea here is
really to let people walk through these
workflows in tutorials and see how the
steps
actually happen um this you know the the
app does interact with Photoshop and
lets you and listens to what's happening
so if the user doesn't want to just
press those buttons but actually wants
to follow the instructions which we
think is really the right thing to do if
you want to learn it they can go through
and and do those steps and the tutorial
player will respond to the user and
actually scroll the tutorial for them
automatically and the idea here is to
really try and stay in sync so that the
user can more easily follow what's
happening and and this works not just
with the sample images that are part of
each tutorial but the user can of course
use their own images and the tutorial
will respond in the exact same way and
so at this point you're probably
thinking well merely this is really cool
but what if you're how do you create
these tutorials presumably your library
is not the entire web which is full of
all kinds of interesting tutorials and
oops and so to create these types of
interactive tutorials we've created a
plug-in called tutorial builder um and
tutorial builder is there it just has
two buttons is very simple what it does
is it takes a demonstration of the
technique that you want to do in
Photoshop and it automatically turns it
into a step-by-step tutorial so all you
have to do is just show show Photoshop
or show tutorial builder what it is that
you want the tutorial to do and it will
just create the text and the steps for
you now the way that happens is inspired
by the way book tutorials are written so
when we started this work we went to to
the really high quality tutorials and we
said okay how are these tutorials why
are these tutorials so effective well
they're effective because first of all
there you know very specific in their
steps their precise and succinct they
also give you a great overview but allow
you to focus on the details and so um we
started with you know our macro
recording which is what photoshop gives
us when you do one of these performances
and to translate that into text we do a
number of steps first we remove any
steps that the user didn't actually do
anything with so if they selected a tool
and it's liked another tool we remove
that tool that they didn't use second we
take any parameter adjusting so maybe
you adjusted just you know the
brightness parameter a little bit and
then you went back and adjust it again
well you don't want steps that show show
exactly that we collapse those together
and turn them into one step and then
finally we create the text by using
templates so here is what a template
might look like use the blank tool to
select the blank and so that becomes use
that you use the ellipse select tool to
select the iris does anything look
interesting here suspicious one yeah
anyone find anything interesting about
this sentence how did you find the iris
good question so um so it's part of the
system we run detectors on the image to
try and guess what the user selected
because if we can know what these are
selected then we can make the text or
general purpose right so that if you
wanted to apply this to another image at
you would want the tutorial if someone
had written that tutorial you'd want it
to say select the eye or select the
mouse not select the region is shown on
the right um when possible we also
capture images and annotate those images
to help the user translate those
instructions and then finally we lay out
the tutorial originally when we started
we we modeled the book tutorials that we
were inspired by as you saw i tutorial
player that the layout now is is much
more web web focused and follow-on work
we've been really interested in walking
this boundary between video tutorials
and text and image tutorials and so
we've created what we call mixed media
tutorials and what we did was
essentially take tutorial there as you
just saw it which is essentially letting
you do a demonstration and we paired it
with a screencast o
the exact same demonstration and we
automatically segment that screencast
and embed those pieces of the screencast
that correspond to each step right
alongside the step and so what does that
look like um so here is the removing
objects with the pen tool if you scroll
through this tutorial you see that it
looks just like a static tutorial with
with images but in fact each one of
these is a video and so you see the
user's mouse here and and this is
actually a cropped version of this
screenshot of the original screencast
and you can see the entire screen cast
oops in the normal view so this is what
we actually captured you can also look
at a zoom view if you prefer to just you
know look at the parts of the interface
that are currently being used well you
can look at them in the crop mode which
is removing everything extraneous and we
generate this fully automatically so um
the other thing we've been doing is
thinking about how can we take videos
and make them more usable and so here
I'll show you the positive play system
and this system takes existing videos
that you could find on the web and then
tries to segment them to make them
adaptive to the user so on the left you
see the user using google sketchup on
the right is the actual tutorial video
and what happens is as the user is using
Sketchup the video player is
automatically pausing and playing to try
to stay in sync with what the user is
doing so here you know there's the first
step which is to draw a rectangle and
then extrude I think that rectangle and
so when the tutorial gets to a different
tool it will pause and it will tell the
user go activate this tool and when the
user selects that tool the video
automatically starts playing so the user
doesn't have to keep switching back and
forth between the video and
application the application is just
playing they can just listen to it or
they can look at it and they can
continue operating in their application
at the same time and in contrast with
tutorial builder where we had to
actually create an authoring tool to
make this Richard kind of tutorial here
we're doing everything after the fact so
we take the tutorial video we use
computer vision to parse it to figure
out which tools are being used and then
we segment it and then the video player
itself is listening to what's happening
in the application and automatically
pausing and playing playing that video I
think the one thing I wanted to mention
is that the disadvantage of this
approach is that we can't do the show me
buttons so we can't actually do the
operations for the user because we don't
have the command we can't extract that
just from the video ok yes oh I screw up
even when trying to follow tutorial and
it seems like there's an entire sort of
open area or challenge here of what
happens when a user gets off the rails
right um and if they start thrashing for
example day I suddenly click the button
that the things expecting them to click
but they're actually a few steps pop out
of sync and so on mm-hmm um I wonder if
there's an opportunity to take this
notion sort of opportunistic learning to
say to as it I got no this far and then
like spokes me here because otherwise
you're in start rolling on without right
um yeah so we haven't so in both in
tutorial player and in pause and play we
don't do any long-term comparison we're
very much just comparing kind of where
you are right now and what you're doing
next um I think it would be really hard
to do something fully automatic just
because the user can really go off the
rails unintentionally or intentionally
right maybe you decide oh this is really
interesting and I want to explore this
further I'm just going to like take a
break from the story
so um well he's not the way to think of
it I wonder this is just me what price I
don't know if you were to look at sort
of over the time of a tutorial how and
then like the y-axis is how important is
it that you ask the person actually see
that information right is it like
uniform do I actually need to follow
step by step as you pointed out where is
it actually the case that most people
actually just need this this might eat
it and they tend to fast forward right
ah yes so I think the idea of doing
hierarchical tutorials is really
interesting and I think that's
particularly useful for different
expertise levels so you know a true
beginner might need really low level
like step by step by step instruction
well a someone that's more advanced
might just need / move the background
and they don't have to follow your
particular way of removing the
background because they know how to
remove the background right so um I
think doing matching at that level is
probably hard but I think you may don't
even need to do the matching right you
could imagine having a tutorial that
like expands and contracts as the user
needs that detail I think what would be
cool actually is if the user starts to
follow a step so so we've done some work
actually looking at the content itself
and trying to adapt macros based on
content and so I think that's another
interesting direction so you're using
this example tutorial but it's not quite
right for your tutorial for your image
how do we adapt that workflow fully
automatically so that it does fit and so
we've done work there on adapting
parameter values which is doable um when
you you know we basically matchup image
features with different parameters and
we know that like for daytime images you
want to pick these parameter values and
for nighttime images you're going to
pick these other ones but we haven't
done that the workflow level but that
would be an interesting an interesting
thing to try yes uh sort of one similar
line
I am sorry that relates to learn more
broadly there's not more broadly if I
get a different my mole of not with
playing follow these steps but I get
what's going on right so r instance
gonna API classes quarter when you're
putting people through things which are
all play like tutorials and about
halfway through the quarter we switch to
giving them less on the rails
suggestions what to do with intention of
this will help them actually learn
that's going on better share in case if
you thought about that yes yes so and
I'll in fact you know this perfect segue
because in some of the game stuff we've
done we're looking at exactly this and
you can have tutorials which are very
prescriptive do this do this do this or
you can have much more open-ended tasks
which are you know this is your this is
your task try to find your own way
through the application and and I think
there are trade-offs in both approaches
so let me show you what we've done with
the games and I think you know at the
highest level novices have a hard time
with the more open-ended stuff but the
more open-ended stuff tends to stick
with them longer so if you can actually
I think that's what the psychology
educational psychology literature shows
that if you can actually figure out your
own way through the task then you will
remember it much more so than if you
just follow a tutorial so so are our
idea if we're trying to do the more
self-guided approach in the context of
learning when it comes to games was in
came in the form of jigsaw and I'll just
start playing this video and but the
idea of jigsaw was to not use tutorials
it was to try and give you a task that
you could do in the software that would
force you to learn a specific tool so
the most basic puzzle we created and we
use the idea of jigsaw puzzle
so the most basic puzzle we created was
one that teaches you about layers so
here each puzzle piece is actually just
sitting on a different layer and all you
have to do is select the right layer and
then move the puzzle piece in the right
spot and after you do this you ask the
system to check your work and it gives
you points and tells you if you're
finished and you know um so this worked
really well for very simple for this
very simple task the thing we we found
that was cool that you could actually
apply this for more complicated tools
too so this is the selection selection
tool puzzle so here all the puzzle
pieces are now sitting on one of the
same layer and they have a background
and so now you have to figure out which
selection tool you want to use to cut
those puzzle pieces out and again place
them in the in the in the right blocks
you can keep going with this so we also
tried this with adjustment layers where
you have to adjust some of the puzzle
pieces and we tell you which adjustment
layer to use and here it's really more
about exploring the different parameter
values and learning how they influence
you know adjusting the image and so this
is a more exploratory approach to
learning and we did do some evaluation
and we found that for those people who
had some background it was effective but
for those who didn't it was quite quite
challenging because telling people oh go
look at this go use this tool is not
always sufficient you need help often if
you can't find it so you really need to
do scaffolding and so the the other game
that I was going to show you is called
level up for photoshop and it's one that
we've been studying for much longer than
jigsaw and this one is back to this idea
of using these more prescriptive
tutorials and so here is how level up
works much like tutorial player it has
interactive tutorials they're presented
as mission
and every mission has points and so as
the user completes the different steps
they get points so here this mission is
to make the image sharper and so the
user is going to use the smart sharpen
filter to to make a chopper and so go
ahead and fast-forward so when they're
when they are finished they get points
and then they're also able to do quizzes
and when they finish with the quizzes
there's also badges and of course they
can share them and and get their friends
to play too one of the things we added
um is more open-ended which is around
this idea of challenge rounds and here
what we did is we said well we'll let
people learn skills with the missions
and then we'll let them test those
skills and challenge rounds and to make
this even more interesting we're going
to make these challenge rounds actually
real-world tasks so these are images
that were submitted to us from
nonprofits and they you know want these
much better looking images and so our
question was can we a you know motivate
these players to do better by giving
them real world context and be could
this be a crowdsourcing platform for
people like the Wildlife Center for
Silicon Valley to get better looking
images and so here the user could for
any of these challenge images the user
could follow suggestions or in addition
they could do their own improvement so
here doing cropping and then they could
upload it to our servers to be sent back
to those organizations and so we've been
sitting level up for two years now and
we've done a bunch of a few different
deployments and the first one we did was
really looking at the tutorials
themselves and then the subsequent ones
we've been really interested in the
crowdsourcing aspect and seeing how we
can combine learning and crowdsourcing
together to improve both
and we've the way we've been doing the
analysis for this has been through logs
through interviews and surveys so in our
first our first deployment started a in
September of 2011 and it lasted for a
year and we had about 5,000 over 5,000
active players and you would think that
you know even when you have three levels
which is not a lot it's for missions
three levels you think everyone would
complete it but no they don't only about
thirty five percent of people complete
this in and keep in mind that these are
people who are going they're all on
their own to even get to the point of
actually installing level up takes quite
a bit of effort and so if they got to
the point of playing they were very
motivated so it's actually surprising to
us that they didn't then that not
everyone completed the game but you know
we had some specific questions in mind
in particular what was was the tutorial
format effective and one of the things
that people pointed out was it by
embedding these tutorials inside the app
essentially pulling him off the web and
embedding them it became easier for them
because they didn't have to go out and
search for them they knew that they were
always there also because they came from
Adobe they were vetted they were better
somehow because they knew who they were
coming from one user said it got me to
try things and gave enough instructions
I was able to rapidly make progress
usually I get lost trying to find the
item I'm looking for so this really
speaks to the idea that you can use this
approach to really focus the user and
stop them from getting overwhelmed by
the interface and I think that's the
value in these interactive experiences
that try to really focus you on click on
this do this don't worry about the rest
one thing that was surprising to us is
that people reported playing for points
so you know going out to like just try
it out because it's a game but then
using the panel as a reference down the
road so two weeks later you remember oh
I have this task I remember I did this
with the game but I don't remember all
the details let me open it up and
actually use it as interactive torch is
an interactive tutorial rather than just
something that I'm playing to get points
and that's a side benefit of this
tutorial format that we really didn't
anticipate I mean I felt that you know
these tutorials are maybe too boring I
mean they're just step by step by step
right I I really thought that the jigsaw
format would be more interesting because
you would be pushed to really explore on
your own um one key question of course
with these things is did people actually
learn anything new and we looked at
actual application logs to try and get
at that and yes indeed everybody who
played tried a new tool that they had
not used previously in there you know in
the logs that we have for them and
eighty-three percent of those people
continued using those new tools after
exposure to level up one thing that was
really exciting is that you know when we
developed level up it was really
designed for novices a lot of these
missions are very basic photo editing
things you know sharpen this remove
redeye remove wrinkles but what we but
what we found is when we talked to more
advanced users they said wow you know I
never knew this feature existed I've
been doing this same thing in this case
you know this user was talking about
straightening a photo I've been
straightening a photo in this other way
and I just found out about the ruler
tool and it's amazing you're going to
save me hours of time and so I'm that
was really great it meant that you know
this this had benefit for not just the
beginners but also for the advanced
users so it really serves as a vehicle
for discovery at which an application
like Photoshop has a big problem with
because it has so many tools even though
there are new features coming out all
the time you know that the product team
can't necessarily measure impact of
those new features if people aren't
using them so one user said a lot of it
is just accidental discovery I blame
myself because I haven't been as
diligent about react about reaching out
and finding the resources this is why I
enjoyed the game it was fun and the
exercises were brief enough not to cause
one to become frustrated they introduced
me to features and functions that I
never knew existed
and so in our second deployment we
really were excited about looking at the
crowd sourcing piece and combining crowd
sourcing and learning together to see
how they could benefit each other and so
we collected images from two nonprofits
from the Wildlife Center for Silicon
Valley designed for America which is a
student organization I donated my
personal photos real hardship on me and
and then we got photos from Adobe as
well and so we were really interested to
see how people would react to these and
and not only that but given it you know
this is a tool that was made for novices
would they do a good enough job of
editing these images so we did a four
month deployment it started in September
2012 we had 3,500 active players and
over that time they submitted over 8000
images the majority were novices with
some intermediate and expert users um
each image that was that was part of the
data set was improved by at least eight
people and we had 10 people who improved
over 10 over a hundred images and this
is what this the distribution looks like
this is submitted one image so a third
of our players submitted only one image
a quarter submitted to and then another
quarter submitted more than four or more
and so I just want to give you a sense
for what people actually did so here's
here's one user who did a really good
job in improvement so i would say that
there were many improvements that were
actually quite quite nice which was
which is great so this is not something
that we taught them how to do in the in
the game we did teach them how to remove
you know unwanted objects but you know
we never asked them to remove leashes in
particular here's another image that was
edited that was definitely much better
they for example the background here has
been blurred and the woman is is much
brighter
a lot of people applied effects so here
you see that this car you know has this
more as more stylistics more stylized
you know whether this is an improvement
or not is kind of a subjective metric
depending on what the task is that you
want to use this image for here is
another filter this image of a cat is
particularly challenging I think but
this user managed to do a really good
job here I'll show you a few submissions
for this one particular image on the
left and there are just different and I
would argue all our veteran in slightly
different ways so here's another one you
know here is another one some people did
very basic improvements for example
straightening this image and some people
really took it in a whole other place um
and you know clearly showed that they
had skills beyond what we were teaching
them and really had a lot of fun I would
argue with the game and then some people
tried to talk to us keep in mind that
there was no way for them to text with
us or to text it each other or
communicate with each other but they
found this game a little too easy and
then not everybody did a good job I mean
so lots of people tried and you know I
would argue didn't actually succeed but
they tried um interestingly we so this
person you know submitted this image but
didn't really do do anything useful we
didn't we looked for cheaters we were
curious to see if I'm like another
crowdsourcing platform like mechanical
turk if there would be cheaters but we
really didn't find any cheaters mainly
because there was nothing for them to
gain by cheating right like these are
people who are learning the only reason
that they're using the software is for
their own benefit and so we looked at we
try to more rigorously assess the
quality of the images you know the we
selected a subset and we did three
different assessments we asked the
requesters
elves if the nonprofit requesters what
you know for the images that were
submitted which ones they would pick
whether it would be the original or the
submitted and varied by by organization
so twenty to sixty percent of those
submitted images were considered better
than the originals we also did a
mechanical turk task where we asked
Turkish which image they would pick
could be a for professional website and
there the Turkish found thirty-seven
percent of the submissions better than
the originals and then we also had
experts rate the images and the experts
had a lot more information about the
kinds of tasks that the players were
asked so they knew about the kinds of
things they had learned in the levels
and they knew about the hints that they
were given you know whether they should
be addressing brightness or
straightening the image and so the
experts found that eighty-five percent
of the submissions were rated as same or
better and this because again they had a
lot more context yes slowly see violence
is 37th oh yeah it seems like the
exploits are not judging quality of the
output rather they're judging the
quality of the process ok so it was
really hard to try and figure out how to
judge quality to begin with um because
there were two different things right
there was is this a bit so there is the
subjective is this a better looking
image and that's a very subjective thing
and then if they say did they did they
complete what they were asked to do and
so that's really more about the process
and so the expert raiders did a
combination of quality and process so if
they I think the experts if the users if
the players did what they were asked to
do and it looked better you know then
they would consider it we actually used
a two-tiered rating system usefulness
and novelty and usefulness was is this
better than the original based on what
they were asked to do and then the
novelty was did they use the two
that they learned in that level or did
they use you know did they go beyond
that so um so yes I guess to answer your
question yes they were definitely
looking at provide process in addition
to quality it is summer bedroom because
it's Australian again which of these to
be parlayed into the Austin against you
I mean I think any other day like that
was going to consume those images so
that's really all that matters um
because the Turkish yeah I mean you're
getting a general there you're getting a
general opinion of is this a good image
or not which you know they're not the
ones that are going to use it at the end
so i think what what what was exciting
is that our novices did really well so
seventy-eight percent of the novices
submitted at least one image that was
rated as better than original which is
which is great um so in the end I think
level for photoshop is an effective
mechanism for teaching people new skills
and for leading to discovery of these
more efficient workflows and I think
it's an interesting point in the space
of crowd sourcing platforms it combines
learning and crowdsourcing in a new way
and most crowd sourcing platforms today
don't consider how to embed learning as
part of as part of the crowd sourcing
process so i would like to conclude
until in saying that I think learning or
using software has really changed and
last let's say 10 years people are
really learning opportunistically and we
really need to think about how to teach
them so that they can be successful in
these opportunistic endeavors and so I
have a number of ongoing projects which
I'll just mention quickly and first
we're taking all the learning work that
we've been doing with with applications
and we're thinking about how to use that
in the real world so with collaborators
at Berkeley we're looking at how to make
it easier for example to author
videos instructional videos for DIY
tasks and this is a system that tries to
make it as easy it tries to take frame
video frame editing out of the picture
so all you have to do is say this is a
step one step two step three step four
and then the system will automatically
segment that video and and even apply
effects to it and and cut it ready for
you to share um we're also we're also
looking at how to do workflow
recommendations so based on this idea
because we found that people are really
not good at at discovering new workflows
on their own we're trying to think about
how we might um mine was happening in
the application and suggest alternative
workflows or alternative features to
users and then finally I'm really
interested in understanding user
behavior more generally and so right now
we're working on building visualization
tools to try to understand how people
use applications how they travel through
websites and to help there's already a
lot of analysts that are trying to
understand this behavior in the digital
marketing space and so we're building
tools to help them understand this type
of behavior and so with that I'd like to
thank you all for coming and thank all
these collaborators this is not work
that I've done by myself as a big team
of people from a lot of different
universities and Adobe and so I'm happy
to answer any questions
yes I all contribute to nutrition like
like a compared to like after each
individual doesn't like word with the
challenges to give me two more people
talking out no the the rate of
completion was pretty much the same with
the janella grounds so that I should say
that they did not have to do the
challenge rounds they could skip through
them oh just they were not required yes
oh sorry just on that you didn't check
it just the presence of the challenges
cause what I think is Erik Anderson
looking at Soren I knew how bet
university of washington at this study
for showing that the presence of things
like extra coins again he didn't have to
get cause trisha in the stairs mm-hmm so
and we looked at completion rates for
those levels and there was no difference
between having the challenges and not
having the challenges and i don't know
if it's because you know they're more
than just like little gimmicky coins
right they're different and flavor there
an entirely different activity that's
right it's up to you if you want to do
it but I mean that's not all that
different than the coins it would be
interesting to understand like why in
that context those were detrimental and
in our case it didn't seem to matter yes
if if I if I think if you're talking
with us it's not over the tutorials can
you say you can do national language or
editing orphanages I don't think that if
you have that language rating of
religious right why would you want to
learn how to use photoshop right if I
can get the pictures to look good
without my learn if i woulda done right
oh I think it's all comes down to
whether you are teaching people skills
that are more generalizable our weather
something is a specific to a particular
application which will be outdated in
the next five years when you're easily
watching and so that when you see you
know the natural language part fell and
the tutorial project you know looking so
that's a great point I think the natural
language piece can couple quite nicely
with the tutorial piece um you know I
think the natural language interface is
essentially accessing a set of macros
that you could pre-define right you can
think about these like preset workflows
that you could access to the natural
language but those are never going to be
complete and you're going to always have
people who are going to want to go off
and do their own things so I think it's
about the audience right who is your
audience and I think there will be an
audience that that just cares about
getting their thing done and they will
just want the natural language and that
may be the larger audience and then
you'll have an audience that wants to
tinker and wants to you know learn the
details I guess that's right I also
think that this this post oriented
analysis might be larger than simply
notices because if you look at staff
over here mm-hmm I don't consider myself
a bad programmer right but if I have to
solve the problem I'm not going to think
through it if there's a solution and
stackable it up what's right in here so
yeah so I think if you if you reduce the
complexity of meeting some excerpts then
you might find professionals also using
dynamic language much yeah for these
subsets of their work was yeah that's
true basically there's some optimal
amount of difficulty because if you took
some of this project that could just
automatically execute the tutorial right
and it's like I knew before it go well
they didn't actually learned anything
right um in the ocean so at some point
was if it's so hard to figure out then
Camaros
by a mountain so I wondered well hey if
we have any Theory enough basically
status how right how much hands holding
you need a new video in research can
tell us they're right um or maybe or
maybe we don't use theory we simply like
do some like MC MC thing where we're
just actually trying different
approaches and finding the optimal
educational approach for this yeah I
mean I think so what hasn't been done i
think is looking at work clothes kind of
an wholesale like you can't for example
very easily if you could take a workflow
and automatically throw your image at it
which actually we've done in and work
that i didn't talk about today what
hasn't been done is thinking about how
you might what are that all the
variations of a workflow so today when
you when you do any image editing
workflow or any other really workflow
you're following a set of steps and
you're you know setting those parameters
and once you're down that road you can't
really go back and change those
parameters right like that's it and so
having a way to actually modify those
variables on the fly and seeing the
whole workflow I guess exploring the
space of a workflow could be really
interesting and that would be a very
different skill that would only be
possible if you have kind of a higher
level interaction look whether it's with
natural language or something else sorry
sure yeah so that is my new york so
these workers are really tool to
children composited together and i think
that there is some sort of a directed
graph of these students so you can pick
a starting point you can have multiple
ending points for that act right so i
think one way then as a steward i might
benefit from these tutorials is to say
oh and now that you learn the step you
can also use it for these four other
things which are not really related to
your client work right you know this is
kinda stuff you could be doing right
as particular it's taking a repository
of tutorials and aligning them so that
you can have alternative workflows for
pieces of those entire workflows and
then you could of course match along
tools as well and say how could I use
this tool what are all the different
possible ways yes there's that one
remaining edit professional designer and
I also teach students about designing as
ownership and photoshop itself is very
specific to old as we all rely on today
audience is it has a large tool set but
i'm wondering if you looked at other
models of learning that are outside of
and photoshop outside designed and for
this research and it is what are the
lumens per message that are you i guess
i really am something in particular like
a specific domain how to teach students
down design but how can i apply this
design teaching two areas outside with
the time as well so if you're asking a
very broad question so i'm not sure if
i'll answer um what what you're asking
they're rooting models out sure
photoshop need an educational approaches
or other platforms um either so i've
been very focused on you know design
software in particular I think I haven't
you know look the other thing we've
looked at his creativity which is I
think um different and that it's it's
it's not tools Pacific it's much more in
the head than it is you know with the
hands and there is definitely you know a
big difference between learning a craft
which is you know what you might call
learning photoshop versus learning how
to design right how to be a good
designer is as much about ideas it is
not about like being able to brainstorm
and and explore lots of ideas as it is
about you know manipulating a tool right
and so I think I don't know
other what we've learned here would
directly apply in the creativity space
probably not i mean you know i think to
the i think for sure what we've learned
here would apply to other kinds of
crafts like programming for example and
programmers today extensively used the
web and they would have in fact a very
hard time programming if the web was to
disappear right so many people can't get
on a plane and program because they may
not have access to the internet so i
would say that what we've seen here
would apply to other crafts so I think
we're seeing the same thing in the DIY
space so people go to youtube for help
all the time but if you want help to
become more creative I don't know how
you would do that right you would go and
probably read books and you would go and
talk to people it would be kind of a
different type of I think learning
environment sure cuz it continuing to
question so probably it before users
they are looking for a network to change
the arm and that's right now maybe
that's part of your research yes you
know what is the most popular think you
go right what is the most popular yeah
so there's definitely opportunities
around communities and and in fact we've
had various kind of projects and in the
past that look at what would a Photoshop
was friends look like and and level up
in particular is very single user and
we've always wanted to make it much more
collaborative and so I think there's
lots to be done around collaboration and
learning in particular so yet yes I'm
still is instructional technology and
business sure we have for our
interesting project with Wikipedia a
mission also in Wikipedia they long term
project cost I'll we keep the education
program so ready
target is the college level students at
prices so they encourage the professor's
to construct a first page of PDF and for
the peace master students collaborate
with each other to added the whole
project or the topic okay the promises
into the cancer thing most of course
poor of Medicine so what I wanna get a
row different students from each year to
add it wore them so it's about
interesting project but since they just
a bumptious it's correct so they want to
do a usability tasking and I just feel
the research you did with the adobe
program is very interesting so I'm I
want to know more detail like how you
lead on the violation or the animated
and I wonder whether i can find the
research paper or some some more details
about the research enemy or is that
possible way too soon yeah so a lot of
the work that I've shown you today is
already published the only thing that's
kind of still coming out is the most
recent level up and crowdsourcing work
but I'm happy to share a draft of the
paper so um yeah I mean you're you're
definitely welcome to go to my website
and look at the papers and feel free to
contact me if you have questions and
I'll check out this education we could
be education and website I wasn't aware
of it yeah we'll take the other
questions offline but thank you see you
one more time
you